[موسيقى]
الاسواق الشعبيه في ولايه نزوى لها نكه
خاصه كسوق الجمعه الذي نحن فيه الان فما
ساعات الفجر الاولى يتوافد التجار من خلال
هذا الباب لبيع الاغنام والاسماك والابقار
الى جانب الخضروات والفواكه وغيرها من
البضائع
[موسيقى]
الحركه التجاريه الناشطه في هذا السوق تعد
مثالا للاسواق الشعبيه التقليديه وانعكاس
لتاريخ الولايه العريق بحضارتها المتمثله
بقلاعها وحصونها وبيوتها الاثريه وحاراتها
القديمه
[موسيقى]
من خارج ولايه نزوى ومن خارج المحافظه على
مستوى السلطنه سوق نزوى يتميز
بتعدد الاغراض المتوفره فيه همم بكافه
انواعها
وهو سوق تراثي سوق حرافي سوق اقتصادي بكل
ما تعني الكلمه من معنا
[موسيقى]
الاطفال لهم حضور في سوق نزوى رفقه ابائهم
كي يتعلموا التجاره مبكرا
[موسيقى]
فسبنا مثلا تجاره من الاباء من قبل واحنا
كنا صغار
الوالد في السوق واكتسبنا يعني مثل هذه
التجاره والحين ما شاء الله الحمد لله
مستمرين عليها واكيد راح التجاره يعني
علمهم على هيئه التجاره والاستمرار فيها
في سوق نزوى من النادر ان تشاهد اجنبيه
يمارسوا التجاره الغالبيه هنا من الشباب
العمانيين
كما تلاحظ ان سوق نزوه وسوق من تاريخ
وثقافه الولايه في المنطقه ومن سارف العصر
كان سوق نزوى عقب
بالزباينه ونزلوا مقصد سياحي ومقصد تجاري
في نفس الوقت
[موسيقى]
في هذا السوق فعاليات متنوعه لجذب الزوار
يستطيع الزائر ان يؤجر بالساعه سياره
كلاسيكيه ليتجول بها في انحاء نزوى
القديمه عبد الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه
الزوار العربيه
[موسيقى]